good morning believe nation today's
messages think big over to you Kelly
Slater I come from a small city in
Florida in Central Florida and there's
not too many people my city who sort of
spread out around the world night I live
around the world I travel around the
world knit it's it's really great it's a
lot of fun but I think as a kid I had a
lot of ideas that were really big and
both my parents had passions that they
never really followed my both my parents
loved to play music dad play guitar my
mom loved to sing and play banjo my dad
did a little bit of Seattle acting and
but they never really followed their
dreams neither one of them you know and
I think that was one thing my mom always
wanted for me she always wanted me to
follow my dreams and to think big don't
you know don't just think of like you
know just a little problem you have at
school or just a little I mean you got
to take care of those things too but
it's thinking about the you know someone
like that all I long what he's thinking
about the whole world every time it
makes a decision you know and and if
people think if more people think that
way more big great things happen so I'm
in Madrid and I just got back from a
talk for librarians to help them think
bigger and help them stay relevant
because libraries are getting budget
cuts losing funding on the verge of
extinction according to some people and
I don't want them just to be relevant I
want them to be great that was the theme
of my talk I look at before I came out
looked up famous libraries in the only
thing that kept coming up over and over
and over again was the Great Library of
Alexandria something
how some ever out for thousands of years
no you guys can do better I don't want
you just to be relevant I want you to be
great again I want you to build a
library that will last for thousands of
years that in a thousand years people
will still be talking about the great
things that you created right and I want
that for you too as entrepreneurs you
know getting by isn't enough having a
little impact isn't enough I want you to
think bigger if you have the talent you
have the ability you have the hustle you
the drive I want you to build something
that will have a big impact on people
and that people will tell their
grandkids about because it was so
special what you created and that's
motivating that's exciting people don't
get excited about doing little things
right to motivate yourself to motivate
your team to motivate the media to
motivate investors what are the people
around you you have to be doing
something that is worth getting excited
about so do that build something that
when you look at it I can't wait to go
and do that initiative think bigger I
got on a bit of a rent there I'm excited
so the question today today is I want to
know what stops you from thinking big
leave in the comments below join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot I've been
stressing